[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a esta primera edición del
2023 de corresponsales el programa de
France 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas dado el corte en los
suministros de gas por parte de Rusia
Europa tenía las consecuencias de un
invierno que pudiera ser demasiado frío
sin embargo tras más de 15 días ya
adentrados en esta estación la realidad
es toda la contraria hay días soleados
récords de temperatura en múltiples
países y estaciones de esquí sin nieve
los expertos aseguran que estamos
viviendo en carne propia las
consecuencias del calentamiento global y
que este tipo de fenómenos se harán cada
vez más repetitivos con el pasar de los
años informe
piscinas al aire libre abarrotadas A
mediados de enero no estamos en
marrakech es bucarest en Rumanía el
pasado domingo las temperaturas
aumentaron hasta los 20 grados
el mismo ambiente primaveral en Varsovia
Polonia
en República Checa la mitad de las
estaciones meteorológicas han registrado
temperaturas récord que no se veían
desde hace 30 años
en Praga los turistas visitaron la
ciudad en camiseta
en mi casa en Suecia hace mucho frío
nieva Así que tomé esta chaqueta
caliente Espera a temperaturas similares
pero De hecho hace mucho calor
también en Francia las temperaturas
fueron dos veces más altas que los
promedios estacionales una situación que
desconcierta incluso a los meteorólogos
en tiempos normales tenemos una
alternancia de masas de aire ciclónicas
y anticiclónicas
entonces el aire tiene tiempo de
enfriarse allí esa alternancia no existe
esta calidez en Europa se debe a un
flujo de humedad aquí en verde comienza
en el Caribe y se extiende hasta Europa
un fenómeno raro llamado río atmosférico
que podría multiplicarse debido al
cambio climático y el calentamiento de
los océanos
una Plus de evaporaciones hay más
evaporación y por lo tanto más humedad
en el aire cuando este es más cálido
Entonces es el calor y la humedad
combinados con las corrientes de aire
que va más de Sur a Norte lo que está
causando estas temperaturas
un clima moderado con consecuencias
directas para muchas estaciones de esquí
en Europa aquí en Austria Las pistas son
transitables gracias a Los cañones de
nieve para las estaciones más bajas las
condiciones ya no son suficientes aquí
en los pirineos Las pistas de esquí
tuvieron que cerrar esta semana
India despenalizó la homosexualidad en
el 2018 con un histórico fallo que
abolió la pena de hasta diez años de
cárcel que pesaba sobre las personas de
la comunidad lgbtiq Más sin embargo el
tema del matrimonio entre personas del
mismo sexo sigue siendo un tabú en el
país es por eso que el tribunal supremo
empezó a estudiar las demandas
presentadas por dos parejas homosexuales
que buscan que este tipo de uniones sean
finalmente legalizadas un tema complejo
en un país mayoritariamente conservador
y en el cual el gobierno tendrá la
posibilidad de exponer sus argumentos a
favor y en contra el siguiente es un
reportaje de Albán Álvarez y nabobita
cumari
al sur de India su brillo y abjey su
pareja hace 10 años a finales de 2021
celebraron una ceremonia en la que
intercambiaron sus votos en presencia de
sus seres queridos una Unión presentada
en su momento como uno de los primeros
matrimonios entre personas del mismo
sexo en el país
un día pensé Por qué esperar nuestros
amigos y familiares saben que somos
pareja nuestros amigos nuestros colegas
nuestros estudiantes todos nos han
mostrado siempre su apoyo Porque esperar
Hagamos una ceremonia llamemos a todos
nuestros familiares y demostrémosle que
estamos juntos y sobre todo felices de
estar juntos
sin embargo cuatro años después de la
despenalización de la homosexualidad el
matrimonio gay sigue sin estar permitido
en indias los dos hombres han recurrido
el tribunal supremo para que se
reconozca oficialmente su Unión y así
dar más visibilidad a las parejas lgtv
el matrimonio sigue siendo un momento
muy importante en la sociedad India si
no estás casado en cómodo estás excluido
así que si se produce Este cambio Si por
fin conseguimos el derecho a casarnos
legalmente automáticamente eso hará que
seamos más aceptados por esta sociedad y
también iniciará un verdadero debate que
permitirá que otras personas salgan del
armario y proclamen su sexualidad alto y
claro
disfrutar de los mismos derechos que las
parejas heterosexuales esto es también
lo que reivindican parte y ude son
pareja desde hace 17 años y están
criando dos hijos concebidos mediante
gestación subrogada pero la
imposibilidad de unirse ante la ley les
impide ejercer plenamente de sus
derechos paternales oficialmente soluude
es reconocido como padre de sus dos
hijos
tenemos dos hijos juntos pero no tengo
estatuto legal legalmente no existo no
soy su padre Qué debo hacer tengo que
luchar por este derecho si mi pareja
muriera tendría automáticamente derecho
sobre mis hijos no si uno de mis hijos
tiene que ser hospitalizado mi pareja no
está presente y solo un familiar cercano
puede tomar una decisión médica de
urgencia soy yo Ese familiar cercano
tampoco next
si las próximas semanas el tribunal
supremo falla a favor de las uniones
entre personas del mismo sexo India
seguiría el único precedente asiático el
de Taiwán que reconoció el matrimonio
gay en 2019
en Mali fueron liberados los 49
militares de Costa de Marfil que habían
sido acusados de mercenarios y
sentenciados apenas que oscilaban entre
los 20 años de cárcel y la pena de
muerte un gesto que según el propio
gobierno transitorio maliense da muestra
del apego a la paz y al diálogo del
presidente el coronel asimismoita más
detalles en el informe de nuestro equipo
en el terreno
Este es el final de una telenovela que
ha durado siete meses los soldados
marfileños detenidos en julio por Mali
será liberados así lo anunció en una
declaración leída en directo por
televisión el ministro mariense de
administración territorial
su excelencia el coronel asimismoita el
presidente de la transición jefe de
estado ha concedido el indulto con
remisión total de la pena a los 49
marfileños condenados por la justicia
maliense
46 soldados fueron condenados a finales
de diciembre a 20 años de reclusión
criminal por delitos de atentado y
conspiración contra el gobierno tres
mujeres liberadas A mediados de
septiembre fueron condenadas a muerte
por Rebeldía bamaco acusó a estos
soldados de haber viajado con
identidades falsas con armas y sin
informar a las autoridades Costa de
Marfil rechazó las acusaciones afirmando
que sus soldados estaban en una misión
para la ONU esta gracia se produce una
semana después de la visita oficial
abamaco de una delegación madrileña
la transición
[Música]
es indulto refuerza el impulso creado
tras la firma el 22 de diciembre de 2022
del memorando de entendimiento sobre la
promoción de la paz entre Mali y Costa
de Marfil la comunidad económica de
Estados de África occidental había dado
un ultimátum a la junta maliense para
que liberara a los soldados antes del 1
de enero o se enfrentaría sanciones un
plazo ignorado por bamaco el actual
presidente de la cdao se había mostrado
finalmente conciliador prefiriendo dar
una oportunidad a la mediación togolesa
que ha visitado el país en los últimos
días se completa más de un año desde que
una erupción volcánica arrasara partes
de la isla de la palma en las Islas
Canarias españolas estas zonas
devastadas siguen estando fuera del
alcance de los locales sin embargo un
nuevo paisaje que surgió a raíz de los
flujos de lava se ha convertido en toda
una atracción turística dando Nueva Vida
a la economía local informe de
como un dragón dormido las colinas de la
isla de Palma continúan resoplando y
resoplando cubierto de ceniza pero muy
activo el impactante paisaje atrae a
visitantes de todo el mundo como un imán
bastante espectacular Es realmente bueno
de ver un ambiente sereno y de belleza
natural dejado atrás por la erupción
volcánica más devastadora de Europa en
casi un siglo a finales de 2021 la lava
fluyó por la cresta de Cumbre vieja como
un río Al rojo vivo la erupción duró 85
días la más larga en la historia del
archipiélago las casas las tiendas y las
escuelas fueron arrasadas enteras pero
hoy en día los turistas pueden visitar
sitios restringidos en visitas guiadas
caminando por un bosque de Pinos
alfombrado con ceniza negra
a medida que nos acercamos puedes
comenzar a buscar estas bombas
volcánicas otra cosa aquí es señalar que
los pinos se oscurecen aquí se debe a la
falta de clorofila
y no son solo los excursionistas que
sean multiplicado desde la erupción ha
aumentado el número de cruceros que
hacen escala aquí así como el número de
vuelos directos desde España peninsular
y otros lugares una agradable sorpresa
para los negocios en esta Isla canaria
antes menos conocida el volcán haya
ayudado a la palma a posicionarse a que
muchos antes del volcán La Palma la
confundían con Las Palmas de Gran
canaria o con palma de mallorca un
impulso al turismo y a la economía local
es lo que la isla necesita
desesperadamente más de un año después
de que cesó la erupción grandes
extensiones de tierra permanecen
enterradas en cenizas volcánicas la
agricultura ha sido devastada y barrios
como este siguen acordonados y desiertos
debido a los altos niveles de gas tóxico
en el aire que los hacen inseguros para
vivir
Muchas gracias por seguir Este primer
episodio de corresponsales nos damos
cita la próxima semana siga con más
información en France 24 y France 24.com